orders understandably provokes strong
feelings
and so it is my view
that the basis for any solution
shouldn't just be what works but what is
right
the simplest moral framing for this
issue one I believe members on all sides
of this house believe in
is fairness Mr Speaker it is unfair that
people come here illegally
it is unfair on those with a genuine
case for Asylum when our capacity to
help is taken up by people coming
through and from countries that are
perfectly safe
[Applause]
it is unfair on those who migrate here
legally when others come here by
cheating the system
[Music]
above all
on the British people who play by the
rules when others come here illegally
and benefit from breaking those rules
[Applause]
[Music]
to be angry Mr Speaker because they see
what I see which is that this simply
isn't fair
it is not cruel
or unkind to want to break the
Stranglehold of criminal gangs who trade
in human misery and who exploit our
system and Lords
enough is enough
[Music]
as currently constructed
the global Asylum framework has become
obsolete
today there are 100 million people
displaced globally hostile states are
using migration as a weapon on the very
borders of Europe and as the world
becomes more unstable and the effects of
climate change make more places
uninhabitable the numbers displaced will
only grow
we have a proud history of providing
Sanctuary to those most in need
Britain helped craft the 1951 Refugee
convention to protect those fleeing
persecution
the right honorable member for
maidenhead passed the world's first
modern slavery act in 2015
and in the last year we have opened our
hearts and our homes to people from Hong
Kong Afghanistan and Ukraine
thousands of families will be setting
extra places around the Christmas table
this year a no one no one can doubt our
generosity of spirit
but today
far too many of the beneficiaries of
that generosity are not those directly
fleeing War zones or at risk of
persecution that people crossing the
channel in small boats
many originate from fundamentally safe
countries
all travel through safe countries their
Journeys are not ad hoc but coordinated
by ruthless organized criminals
and every single Journey risks the lives
of women children and we should be
honest mostly men at sea
Mr Speaker this is not what previous
generations intended when they drafted
our humanitarian laws
nor is it the purpose of the numerous
International treaties to which the UK
is a signatory
and unless we act now and decisively
this will only get worse already in just
seven weeks since I became prime
minister we have delivered the largest
ever small boats deal with France with
significantly more boots on the ground
patrolling their beaches for the first
time UK and French officers are embedded
in respective operations in Dover and
northern France we've reestablished the
Calais group of northern European
nations to disrupt traffickers all along
the migration route and last week this
group set a long-term ambition for a UK
eu-wide agreement on migration
now of course this is not a Panacea and
we need to go much further
over the last month the Home Secretary
and I have studied every aspect of this
issue in detail and we can now set out
five new steps today
first
our policing of the channel has been too
fragmented with different people doing
different things being pulled in
different directions
so we will establish a new permanent
unified small boats operational command
this will bring together our military
our civilian capabilities and the
National Crime agency it will coordinate
our intelligence interception processing
and enforcement and use all available
technology including drones for
reconnaissance and surveillance to pick
people up and identify and then
prosecute more gang lead boat Pilots
we're adding more than 700 new staff and
also doubling the funding given to the
NCA for tackling organized immigration
crime in Europe
second
these extra resources will free up
immigration officers to go back to
enforcement which will in turn allow us
to increase rates on illegal working by
50 percent and it's frankly absurd that
today illegal migrants can get bank
accounts which help them live and work
here
so we will restart data sharing to stop
this
third
it's unfair
and appalling that we are spending five
and a half million pounds every day on
using hotels to house Asylum Seekers
we must
we must end this so we will shortly
bring forward a range of alternative
sites such as disused holiday Parks
former student halls and surplus
military sites we have already
identified locations that could
accommodate 10 000 people are in active
discussions to secure these and More Mr
assembly flush the camera then
it's quite serious to take photographs
in the chamber
no no there was a different camera can I
just say if the member knew they'd take
the photograph won't expect them to
lease and expect them to go to the chair
but it's totally unacceptable when the
branch is speaking to disrupt Mr Black
was it yourself
well I hope it's deleted and speak to
the song can you go out and just have a
chat with the surgeon because it didn't
move that way to me prime minister sorry
about that
these sites will accommodate 10 000
people and we're in active discussions
to secure them and many more our aim is
to add thousands of places through this
type of accommodation in the coming
months at half the cost of hotels
at the same time as we consulted on over
the summer
the cheapest and fairest way to solve
this press this problem is for all local
authorities to take their fair share of
Asylum seekers in the private rental
sector and we will work to achieve this
as quickly as possible fourth Mr Speaker
we need to process claims in days or
weeks not months or years
so we will double the number of Asylum
caseworkers and we are radically
re-engineering the end-to-end process
with shorter guidance fewer interviews
less paperwork and introducing
specialist case workers by nationality
we will also remove the gold plating in
our modern slavery System including by
reducing the cooling off period from 45
to 30 days the legal minimum set out in
the ecat treaty as a result of all of
these changes we will triple the
productivity of our caseworkers and we
expect to abolish the backlog of initial
Asylum Decisions by the end of next year
Fifth and most fifth Mr Speaker and most
significantly
a third of all those arriving in small
boats this year almost 13 000 people are
Albanian
and yet Albania is a safe prosperous
European country it is deemed safe for
returns by Germany France Italy Sweden
it is an EU accession country a NATO
Ally and a member of the same treaty
against trafficking as the United
Kingdom
the prime minister of Albania has
himself said there is no reason why we
cannot return Albanian Asylum Seekers
immediately
last year Germany France Belgium Sweden
all rejected almost 100 of Albanian
Asylum claims
yet our rejection rate
is just 45 percent
that must not continue
so today I can announce a new agreement
with Albania and a new approach
yeah yeah yeah first we will embed
border Force offices in torana airport
for the first time ever helping to
disrupt organized crime and stop people
coming here illegally second we will
issue new guidance for our caseworkers
to make it crystal clear that Albania is
a safe country
third one of the reasons we struggle to
remove people is because they unfairly
exploit our modern slavery system
so we will significantly raise the
threshold someone has to meet to be
considered a modern slave
for the first first time we will
actually require a caseworker to have
objective evidence of modern slavery
rather than just a suspicion
fourth we have sought and received
formal assurances from Albania
confirming they will protect genuine
victims and people at risk of
re-trafficking allowing us to detain and
return people to Albania with confidence
and in line with the ecat treaty as a
result of these changes the vast
majority of claims from Albania can
simply be declared clearly unfounded and
those individuals can be swiftly
returned
[Music]
and lastly we will change how we process
Albanian illegal migrants with a new
dedicated unit Expediting cases within
weeks staffed by 400 new specialists
over the coming months thousands of
albanians will be returned home and will
keep going with weekly flights until all
the albanians in our backlog have been
removed
and in addition to all these new steps
Mr Speaker let the house be in no doubt
that when legal proceedings conclude on
our migration and economic development
partnership we will restart the first
flight to Rwanda
so those here illegally who cannot be
returned to their home country can build
a new life there
but Mr Speaker speak even with the huge
progress we will make with the changes
I've announced today
there Still Remains a fundamental
question how do we solve this problem
once and for all
right it is not just our Asylum system
that needs fundamental reform our laws
need reform too
we must be able to control our borders
to ensure that the only people who come
here come through safe and legal routes
however well-intended our legal
Frameworks are being manipulated by
people who exploit our courts to
frustrate their removal for months or
years on end
Mr Speaker I said enough is enough and I
mean it and that means I am prepared to
do what must be done so early next year
we will introduce new legislation to
make
unambiguously clear that if you enter
the UK illegally you should not be able
to remain here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and swiftly returned either to your home
country or to a safe country where your
Asylum claim will be considered and you
will no longer be able to frustrate
removal attempts with late or spurious
claims or Appeals
and once removed you should have no
right to re-entry settlement or
citizenship
and furthermore if our reforms in
Albania are challenged in the courts we
will also put them on a statutory
footing to ensure the UK's treatment of
Albanian arrivals is no different to
that of Germany or France the only way
to come to the UK for Asylum will be
through safe and legal roots and as
and and as we get a grip of illegal
migration we will create more of those
roots
we will work with the unhcr to identify
those most in need so the UK remains a
safe haven for the most vulnerable
and we will introduce an annual quota on
numbers set by parliament in
consultation with local authorities to
determine our capacity and amendable in
the face of humanitarian emergencies
Mr Speaker that is the fair way to
address this Global challenge
tackling this problem will not be quick
it will not be easy
but it is the right thing to do because
we cannot persist with a system that was
designed for a different era we have to
stop the boats and this government will
do what must be done
Mr Speaker we will be tough but fair and
where we lead others will follow and I
commend this statement to the house
I know called the leader of the
opposition kirst armor
can I thank the Prime Minister for
advanced sites of his statement
and can I join with him in the comments
about the tragic loss of life in
solihull which is unimaginably
unbearable for the families the friends
and the whole of the community
Mr Speaker Channel Crossings are a
serious problem requiring serious
Solutions we need leadership at home and
abroad we need a home office that
functions effectively and we need to
defeat the criminal gangs operating on
the coast
but time and time again this government
has not provided serious Solutions the
Prime Minister sat around the cabinet
table the whole time where there should
have been Solutions we've had unworkable
gimmicks and Mr Speaker as I listened to
that statement
all of that has been said almost word
for word before but last time we had
measures the last time we had
legislation
plenty of newspaper headlines about wave
machines prison ships fantasy Islands
but no effective action all designed to
mask failure to distract from a broken
Asylum system that can't process claims
can't return those with no right to be
here and can't protect our borders
over 40 000 people across the channel
this year that's a record but only two
percent have had their Asylum claim
process what happens the other 98
they're placed in hotels costing around
seven million pounds a day bad for
refugees who want to rebuild their lives
bad for taxpayers and Mr Speaker this
isn't just a one-off bad year 2022 it's
been bad under the Tories for years last
year the percentage of Channel Crossing
Asylum claims process was just four
percent let those figures sink in
because that's the root of the problem
something has to be done to clear the
backlog I've welcomed the commitment to
Fast Track clearly unfounded claims
that's what we've been calling for and
Britain is two years behind so many of
our neighbors and allies have been fast
tracking for years
so can the Prime Minister confirm I want
to have an answer on this that he
intends to CL will clear the backlog by
the end of next year and that's 150 000
cases in the backflow well yeah I know
he said it and we'll be back when in a
year but 150 000 cases including the
hundred thousand have been there for
over six months we need clarity about
that I also welcome more staff for
processing it's appalling they let the
backlog get this big nearly a hundred
thousand cases have been waiting more
than six months for a decision that is
the root cause
but processing is only part of the
answer criminal ging criminal gangs are
sending these people to risk their lives
they Thrive because of a total failure
of any coordinated response or any
effective deterrent to their criminal
activity for months we've been calling
for Action to tackle this root cause a
specialist cell in the National Crime
agency a specialist cell in the National
Crime agency to catch prosecute a
disband criminal gangs we need to be
working internationally to end this
cross-border crime again new staff are
welcome but can he guarantee that will
result in prosecutions for those who put
lives and National Security at risk
and Mr Speaker money is being wasted on
the unworkable unethical plan to deport
people to Rwanda
140 million pounds wasted already not a
single deportation and the most senior
civil the most senior civil service in
the home office is the only one in
government to tell the truth
it doesn't even work as a deterrent
exactly the prime ministers promised
more legislation but the last time the
government legislated to tackle the
broken Asylum system they made it work
they made it work sit Mr Speaker since
the nationality of borders act came into
Force Crossings and delays have
increased 18 000 cases have been put
through the new process adding an
additional six months with only 21
returns that's slow track not fast track
how can you have any credibility to say
new legislation is going to be the
answer the unworkable gimmicks go on so
do the crossings we need to bring this
to an end that means a proper plan to
crack down on the gangs quick processing
return agreement serious solutions to a
serious problem and that is what labor
will offer
[Applause]
my Ministry
prime minister
well Mr I'm Mr Speaker I mean that
speaks for itself quite frankly
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Britain's approach to Illegal migration
throughout his clear career since he's
been elected he's failed on 36 occasions
to vote for
and we heard that again today Mr Speaker
he talks about processing he talks about
the hotels the only way to stop that
problem is to stop the boats Mr Speaker
uh we are the only part we are the only
party Mr Speaker that has a plan to
tackle these issues a new small boats
operational command in the channel deals
with Albania and France cheaper
accommodation tougher immigration
enforcement and new legislation making
it clear in law for the first time that
if you come here illegally you cannot
stay
labor now have a choice show that
they're on the side of the British
people and back our plans to stop
illegal migration
he may want to stand in our way he may
want to block laws we're going to block
the boats yeah
Theresa May thank you Mr Speaker can I
thank my right honorable friend for his
reference to my passing of the modern
slavery act yeah does he agree with me
that in dealing with Asylum claims the
owners must be on the home office to
improve its processing
that contrary to what is said by some
commentators and sadly some members of
this house people smuggling and human
trafficking are distinct and separate
crimes and should not be treated or
spoken of as one and that modern slavery
is a very real and current threat with
too many people brought to this country
into slavery and that we must do nothing
to diminish our world-leading
protections for the victims of this
terrible horrific crime
up well Mr Speaker let me on another
whole house who want to join me in
paying tribute to my right honorable
friend
[Music]
leadership on this issue uh she's
absolutely right it's incumbent on us to
ensure that our processing is Swift and
effective but I know she will want to
join me in ensuring that our
world-leading modern slavery regime
actually helps the people who are most
in need who are most vulnerable they're
the people that need our support and
that's what our reforms today will
deliver later
yeah thank you Mr Speaker and I wish to
begin by passing my thoughts and indeed
those are my colleagues to the families
and friends of those impacted by the
terrible terrible tragedy in solihull Mr
Speaker I'm going to start by saying
something which I think many on the
benches behind the Prime Minister wish
that they could say nobody is illegal
and indeed there is no such thing as an
illegal Asylum Seeker yeah but what we
what we all agree upon Mr Speaker is
that the UK's the UK system is broken
and we can't of course escape from the
fact who has broken it you're here but
in order to address some of the problems
that are faced I do indeed welcome some
of what the Prime Minister has said I
have personally visited Hotel
accommodation and seen the damaging
impacts that those long stays have had
on people within that accommodation so
to hear positive words in terms of
speeding up that process isn't did
something which I hope we can all agree
on but I do however have great concerns
gave concerns about the new proposed
legislation grief concerns about the
proposals in respect of accommodation
and gave concerns about the
one-size-fits-all approach to Asylum
Seekers emanating from Albania
so in that regard I would like to ask
the Prime Minister a very simple
question has he consulted with the
United Nations High Commissioner on
refugees and respect of these proposals
and if if not why not but ultimately the
solutions don't lie in either or any of
those above proposals they lie in
ensuring the safe and legal routes exist
the Prime Minister made reference
extensive reference to Safe illegal
Roots so let him rise to his feet and
outline one one single safe and legal
route maybe perhaps for a family member
of an asylum Seeker in Afghanistan in a
way of course that the Home Secretary
could not just last week and finally
finally Mr Speaker Iberia Miss of all of
us in this chamber not to reflect upon
the independent migration advisory
committee's report from this morning
which detailed how important migration
is
is to our public sector to our private
sector and the deeds and indeed to our
economy so how on Earth does this
government's hostile approach to
migration assist with that proposal
thank you Minister well Mr Speaker I'm
happy to tell the honorable gentleman
that the development secretary met last
weekend uh with the UN High Commissioner
for refugees but what I would say what I
would say Mr Speaker it's a point of
difference between us and the party's
opposite is we shouldn't need the
permission of someone outside to control
our own borders
he he he uh he asked also about Albania
and our approach I would just gently
point out to him that what we are doing
is in line with what almost every other
European country already does with
regard to Albanian migrants and lastly
he made the quite frankly absurd claim
that we don't have safe and legal routes
into the UK Mr Speaker in the last few
years we have made offers of over 450
000 to welcome people from Afghanistan
from Syria from Hong Kong and most
recently from Ukraine and that's because
this is a compassionate tolerant country
Mr speaker and it always will be
parliamentary lead of the SMP can put
down a debate on legal migration for
next week
this subject is illegal immigration
[Applause]
the question in front of the house and
the country is how people can be safe
how they their status can be determined
will the action work is it necessary and
is it right I think most people
listening to this debate whether they
normally support the SMP or label
conservances will say yes it is
necessary it will work it should go
ahead
prime minister well I thank I thank my
honorable Jen for his support and as he
knows this problem is complicated it's
not easy it won't be solved overnight
but I believe the plan that we've
outlined today represents the most
serious step forward in getting a grip
of this problem the the task now for us
is to deliver on it but with his support
and everyone else's I'm confident that
we can surely I'm the first like
committed I am Diana Johnson Mr Speaker
in our report on Small Boat Crossings
published in July of this year the home
Affairs select committee made it very
clear that the number one priority for
government should be to clear the Asylum
backlog so we are very pleased that that
is now starting to be addressed the
backlog of 150 000 has been building
though since 2013. so the more recent
Small Boat Crossings have not broken the
Asylum system and we noted how important
it was to have sufficiently well trained
motivated and supported decision makers
to make those good quality first
decisions but despite promises to
increase decision-making numbers before
targets have been missed and the
attrition rate of Staff in 2021 was a
staggering 46 percent
plus the technology that they use is
creakingly Antiquated and reported by
the inspector of borders and immigration
as hampering productivity so can the
Prime Minister just ensure that he has
sufficient members of staff to carry out
what he's seeking to do and can he just
explain exactly when productivity at the
moment is 1.3 decisions per decision
maker per week with a pilot that the
home office have to increase that to 2.7
decisions per decision maker per week
how he is going to Triple productivity
that's right
well Mr Speaker can I thank the chair of
Select Committee because all actually
excellent questions and the right
questions to focus on what I can what I
can tell her is that we have redesigned
the entire process for case working on
an end-to-end basis which will take
productivity from 1.2 as she says it is
today up to four and we will do that in
a relatively short period of time that's
how we'll cut the initial assign and
backlog by the end of the next year that
process is being rolled out as we speak
she talked about the reason uh for the
backdog is worth bearing in mind that
the number of Small Boat Crossings has
quadrupled in just the last two years
that's the scale of the challenge that
we are facing and that is leading a two
significant strain on the system she
asked about the numbers we have already
doubled the number of caseworkers in the
last year to 1200 and that will be
doubling again in the next uh nine to 12
months and lastly Mr Speaker I would
just say a big part of the reason that
our processing is slower than we would
like is because time and time again
people exploit our system to make late
or spurious claims and that is why our
new legislation will tackle that problem
and I hope it has the support of the
party opposite yeah to Gail
Mr Speaker
um can I first thank my right honorable
friend for his statement and for the
initiatives he's taken with Mr mackerel
and with the prime minister of Albania
as two small but significant steps
forward
I also appreciate the fact that he is
clearly going to take personal charge of
the backlog and ensure that the
lamentable performance of the home
office to date is rectified
but would he agree with me
that the only way that this problem is
going to be sold will be on a
pan-european basis and not domestically
and that if we are going to deal with
this then we have to deal with Schengen
and we have to deal with countries
Beyond Schengen and reach agreements and
when he put use all his efforts to seek
to secure that
five minutes stuck out can I uh I thank
my honorable friend for his excellent
question and also all his very
constructive engagement uh with me and
ministers on resolving this issue I know
he speaks up very well for his local
area on these matters but hen he's
absolutely right which is why it's so
crucial that in the last few weeks we
have not only restarted the Calais group
of European nations meeting which the
Home Secretary deserves enormous credit
for she's also put that group on a
permanent basis making sure that we now
go further working with frontex the
European border agency working towards a
UK EU returns agreement for the first
ever time and that is the path forward
Mr Speaker the best way to solve this
problem is Upstream working with our
allies in northern Europe and the plans
and progress that my honor within the
Home Secretary has made are going to
deliver exactly that Ed David our
thoughts and prayers are with the
families and community in solihull who
have lost their young Sons
Mr Deputy speaker Mr Speaker 97
000 people have been waiting for a
decision on their Asylum claim for six
months or more
that's 97 000 people trapped for months
in home office limbo banned from working
while the NHS social care Agriculture
and Hospitality are all desperately
short of Staff they need
last month Mr Speaker it was revealed
that even the home officer's own
analysis
shows that the right to work does not
act as a pull factor for assigned
Seekers
so will the Prime Minister end this
absurd ban on work
to save taxpayers money and help grow
our economy
the simple answer is no uh Mr Speaker we
won't do that nor will we glance a grant
blanket amnesties has happened in the
past to get the backlog down we will go
through it methodically and properly but
the best way to reduce the pressure on
the backlog is to stop the number of
people coming here illegally in the
first place and if the honorable
gentleman is interested in doing that he
should support our new legislation daily
thank you very much Mr Speaker can I
warmly welcome the announcements today
these will be this is exactly what is
needed I can't think of anything more
articulate than that
can I ask my can I ask my little friend
though to reiterate the importance of
Rwanda and using the Rwanda flight as
part of the measures to address illegal
immigration such an important measure
my modern friend is absolutely right uh
the Rwanda policy is an important part
of our approach to tackling this problem
because it must be the case that if you
come here illegally we can return you
either to your own safe country or an
alternative like Rwanda where your claim
can be processed that's the system we
want to move to Mr Speaker and that's
what we will deliver
Mr Speaker 83 of small boat Asylum
claims that have been made in the last
four years are still waiting a decision
you have an attrition weight of 46
amongst caseworkers how are you going to
achieve your goals
committee we we've redesigned the
end-to-end process for for Asylum
processing it will triple the
productivity of our caseworkers and
we'll cut through the backlog but I say
the same thing to him as I said to
others best way to solve this problem
stop people coming here illegally the
best way to do that is to back on new
legislation
to think I strongly support these
measures from the Prime Minister
particularly the disproportionate
numbers of Albanian economic migrants
who are Pew jumping those genuinely
fleeing that danger I heard not a single
practical solution from opposition
benches just just Collective Amnesia
about what they voted against the Prime
Minister knows I favor safe and legal
Roots as a counterbalance to having
tougher and swifter measures will he
therefore in those safe and legal routes
we need to develop have a dubs two
scheme specifically aimed at
unaccompanied children in Peril and a
proper family reunion scheme with those
with close links to United Kingdom
legally here so we can control and
welcome those generally in need of
safety here
rival is not my uh Royal friend is
absolutely right as as our recent
actions have shown over the last couple
of years this is an incredibly
compassionate and generous country that
has an always well offered sanctuary and
refuge to those who really really need
it we need to do that through safe and
legal routes we want to have that
conversation with him and others whether
it's the Red Cross or the unhcr about
how best to design those routes but we
can only have that conversation and
Implement those routes once we have
proper control of our borders and that's
what we need to deliver First Holy Lynch
sitting in our modern slavery system
that's one slavery system we could all
across these benches be incredibly proud
of it protected victims and modern
slavery but also crucially allow us to
secure prosecutions against those
abusers yeah it's currently taking the
home office 531 days on average to
arrive at a conclusive Brown's decision
for victims and around 90 of those
decisions are positive confirming that
people were indeed victims among slavery
this will affect British and foreign
children as well as adults some of those
locked in county lines gangs as well as
sexual exploitation why is the prime
minister tearing up the non-slavery
system in this way
Mr Speaker that's simply not right we're
very proud of our modern slavery system
and we want to make sure that it
protects those genuine victims of modern
slavery and it's absolutely right that
they get their cases considered properly
the reason that is not happening at the
moment is because the system is being
Deluge with far more all claims that it
was ever designed to cope with when the
impact assessment on the modern slavery
bill was done it anticipated three and a
half thousand claims a year what we are
now facing Mr Speaker what we are now
facing is twelve and a half thousand in
just the first three quarters of this
year and it's right that we focus our
attention on those who most need our
help and in doing so we can get those
people the help they need as quickly as
possible Lee Anderson
Mr speaker Alan I live in a place called
The Real World and in the real world
people know that the vast majority of
people traveling here on small boats are
not genuine refugees
even last week at the home Affairs
select committee the Albanian Ambassador
admitted that everybody coming from
Albania are economic migrants they're
coming here because they can't come to a
legal route by getting Visa so they've
come on small boats so the public get it
even the Albanian Ambassador gets it we
all get it
prime minister when will the opposition
get it and realize that the vast
majority they're coming over are not
genuine Asylum Seekers
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
fantastic champion on this issue and
he's absolutely right we on this side of
the house are on the side of the British
people it's as simple as that the
opposition today have put forward no
plans no action I
[Applause]
Kea when we bring forward legislation to
stop the boats they have a choice do
they want to back our legislation and
back be on the side of the British
people
[Music]
thank you very much Mr Speaker and can I
thank the Prime Minister for an
important Suite of proposals that is
outlined this afternoon and and indicate
that we will constructively engage with
his ministers on any legislation that is
brought forward he has rightfully
highlighted Syria Afghanistan Hong Kong
Ukraine and the pressures that have been
in the home office over the last number
of years where staff are moved
continually from one place to another
and then to passports and back again
that's a large part responsible for the
backlog so he is right to double the
number of caseworkers will the new
Albanian team of 400 that is indicated
form part of that doubling or is that
additional staff or staff that will be
moved from elsewhere
prime minister Mr Speaker that's part of
the doubling and that unit will be
specifically trained to process the
Albanian migrants in line with our new
system and our new policy guidance which
is shortly to be issued by the home
office and in doing that we are
confident that we can start processing
Albanian claims in a matter of weeks
rather than months and with our new
agreement we can swiftly send them back
to Albania that's what the Albania prime
minister thinks should happen that's
what European countries do and that's
what we will do in our country too David
Davis
and I strongly welcome the prime
ministers the seriousness with which the
Prime Minister addresses
uh particularly is focused on stopping
the Albanian gangs
but with respect to the dispersal
sentence when the home office attempted
to introduce the dispersal Center in my
constituency they ignored the local
Authority concerns about health care
public services and Children's Services
they then also ignored the existing
level of Albanian organized crime in
Hull and did not even consult the local
police chief before they moved on the
matter needless to say they didn't
consult any of the local MPS either if
we continue in this mode the home office
will face
material judicial review after judicial
review and the policy will not work so
can we please see a radical Improvement
of decision making in the home office in
this process prime minister well first
of all can I thank my honorable friend
for his engagement with us and his
specific suggestions on tackling the
issue of Albanian migrants I hope he's
pleased by what he's heard today which
reflected much of what he suggested and
on the issue of accommodation look I
agree with him and all members know this
is a tricky issue for us to manage Mr
Speaker but we will manage it with
sensitivity and care and strong
engagement with colleagues and local
authorities I make that commitment to
him and will make sure that that is
followed up on
problems speaker Mr Speaker the Prime
Minister mentioned that he wanted to
work with the UN High commission for
refugees and also the foreign minister
had already met with the High
Commissioner for refugees did he did the
High Commissioner support these measures
and their efficacy
Mr Speaker as I said earlier we believe
in sovereignty on this side of the house
and when it comes to controlling our
borders when it comes to controlling our
borders we will of course act in line
with our legal obligations but we will
do what must be done to fix the
unfairness and make sure we stop illegal
migration Mr Robert butland
speak I commend my right honorable
friend for his practical approach to a
problem that needs practical Solutions
can I in urging him to press on with the
work to improve the efficiency of the
system including the tribunal appellate
system
urged the government to work with the
tribunal procedures committee to
reactivate to detain Fast Track
procedure which has been suspended now
for seven years and which I think could
be a reasonable uh a part of the
solution to this problem
my Rhino more genuine friend obviously
has expertise in this issue he's
absolutely right about that process and
the help it can provide avps know the
immigration Minister and the Attorney
General met recently uh with the
authorities and we'll look forward to
taking forward his suggestions
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker in 17
years as a member of this house I have
never known backlogged in every Avenue
of home office processing to be so great
and so slow and the Prime Minister asked
for suggestions if he really wants to
reprocess the home office's procedures
he could take out the ridiculous rule
that people have to renew their
indefinitely to remain every 30 months
putting the same people back through the
system to come out with the same outcome
he could in a long Fell Swoop reduce the
backlog will he do it
Mr Speaker I just gently point out to
The Honorable lady uh that the backlog
now difficult as it is is half as big as
it was under the last Labor government
so and
and unlike and and unlike then and
unlike then we will not resort to giving
people blanket amnesties Mr Speaker
because that's not the right approach so
thank you Mr Speaker
um can I um warmly welcome this
statement um tackling the backlog is
absolutely key to getting the heat out
of this issue and dealing with it fairly
and firmly and I think the same approach
on Albania is is welcome too but would
my right Noble friend agree that whilst
Albania is the issue of the moment this
will move around the globe and actually
going upstream and tackling the issue
with the criminal gangs
um who have imported their dangerous
business model from the Aegean to the
channel is absolutely crucial I wonder
if you could share his thoughts on that
my audible friend is absolutely right
and that's why we're doubling the
funding uh for operation invigor at the
National Crime agency uh which will mean
that they can disrupt twice as many
organized crime games Upstream that is a
European uh effort and it's proven to be
very successful in the past it will get
double the amount of resources to help
disrupt The Gangs Upstream in the first
place
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr will he agree with me that any
proposed bill or policy that breaches
the U.N Refugee convention or the
European convention and human rights
should be rejected out of hand
Mr Speaker what our legislation will do
is ensure that if you come to this
country illegally you will not have the
right to stay here it's a simple
proposition it's a fair proposition and
it's one that is supported by the vast
majority of people across our country
just really
thank you Mr Speaker can I warmly
welcome my right honorable friends
statement today this is a huge step in
the right direction I'm particularly
encouraged by what he says about
albanians tighter guidance for those
processing decisions but will he extend
that process of tightening Gardens to
other countries where we have an issue
of People arriving but too often they
simply get through the system I think
particularly the country like Vietnam
which is a fast-growing prosperous
country where the case to be an asylum
Seeker is considerably weaker than it
was on the past so will he strengthen
guidance for countries like that as well
hi Minister uh yes is a simple answer Mr
Speaker the 2002 Immigration Act already
has in section 92 the ability for the
Home Secretary to designate safe
countries many are already there and we
will continue to add to them as
appropriate
thank you the Prime Minister talks about
the views of the British public
for the decisions of the parents and it
may be An Inconvenient Truth on this
planet but one in five of those coming
in the small boats are under 18 and it's
verified by the home office not those
people on Twitter for six weeks now I've
been asking his government for the
details of the safeguarding provision
during that time we have had multiple
reports of children who are with their
families in these hotels for months on
end being sexually assaulted and abused
nothing that the Prime Minister
announced today is going to change that
situation and how we treat those
children or apply the same rules to
these children that we do to other
children in temporary accommodation with
their families so will he now at least
do the decent thing and make public that
safeguarding contract so we can see what
provision his government has made to
look after these children and commit
that families will be housed separately
from single people
well Mr Mr Speaker the government takes
its obligations towards children
extremely seriously of course it's right
that they are treated differently and
that's why the immigration Minister has
met with the honorable lady and we
continue to make sure that safeguarding
is followed throughout our processing
system currently
very much Mr Speaker my original friend
is right to identify that illegal
immigration and the associated people
smuggling are Global problems that need
Global Solutions so could I press him to
use his good office to urge the United
Nations to make this a topic for the
next general assembly and to introduce
an annual heads of government conference
that focuses on this issue
well first of all can I pay tribute to
my right honorable friend for the work
she did in bringing about our modern
slavery act she deserves uh praise and
credit for that and she's absolutely
right as I mentioned the global picture
on migration has completely changed
since most of these treaties were signed
it's right that countries like ourselves
update their approach for the modern
problem that we face and I think her
idea is a terrific one Rosie Duffield
thank you Mr Speaker does the Prime
Minister agree with Ember Solomon the
chief executive of the refugee Council
who says in the times today instead of
seeking to restrict the right to Asylum
the government should ensure timely fair
and good quality decisions with access
to legal advice so that those who need
protection are allowed to stay and those
with unfounded claims are returned with
dignity at the same time there must be
more safe routes such as family reunion
an issue that many members across this
house have been raising here for several
years
Mr Speaker I agree with all of that and
that's what the reforms we've announced
today will deliver but the best way to
do that is to ensure that the pressure
on our system is not unsustainably high
and that's why we do need to stop the
flow of new illegal migrants coming here
which is why legislation is important as
well as our Albania deal but I want to
do the same thing that she does Swift
and effective processing of those who
come here through safe and legal routes
and the return of those who
that the legislation that he's announced
is overdue secondly that it needs to be
expressly to distinguish between
economic and illegal migrants on the one
hand and genuine refugees on the other
and that the only way this can be done
in law ultimately is through bypassing
by the notwithstanding formula the
European convention on human rights to
ensure that we can actually achieve the
objectives of he set out and it needs to
be done as soon as possible
Minister Mr Speaker I'm I'm confident
that our legislation will deliver the
Asylum system that we want to see and I
can also give my uh honorable friend the
assurance that it will be coming very
early in the New Year we want to crack
on and solve this problem and I look
forward to having his support John
Morrow
thank you Mr Speaker
um when my mother fled war and famine in
Biafra in the 60s with her three small
children the cargo plane on which we
were traveling that was the only form of
Transport available landed first in
Lisbon
which was the only country that
recognized Biafra at the time
does the Prime Minister feel think that
we should have been obliged to remain in
that safe relatively safe country or
does he agree with my mother that it was
better to travel on to Newcastle where
my grandmother was great thanks Mr
Speaker this this country has and always
will have a proud tradition of welcoming
people here so so and what we need to
make sure is that we can do that and we
can't do that if our system is under
unsustainable pressure from people who
shouldn't be here so by having proper
control of our borders by ensuring that
we create a deterrent effect for those
coming here illegally we will be in a
position so that people do not have to
travel through other countries to get
here that we can work with the UN the
Red Cross and others to provide
Sanctuary for them wherever they are and
in the long run that is the fairest and
most sustainable solution to this
problem
O'Neill thank you Mr Speaker can I
congratulate the Prime Minister upon
targeted and practical measures and
would he agree what he proposes is
entirely consistent with our
International obligations and in
particular entirely consistent with
their obligations under the European uh
convention on human rights and the
European Rights Act is it better to
concentrate on practical measures rather
than the red herring of upending our
domestic human rights legislation which
frankly would be a wasteful red herring
prime minister Mr Speaker I thank Marvel
friend for his support and and he makes
a good point as I've said earlier the
vast majority of European countries
already reject almost 100 of claims from
Asylum Seekers from Albania for example
they are all signatories to the same
conventions and treaties we are so there
is no reason why we should not be able
to move to exactly the same rejection
rate there's several Roberts and I'd
like to ask to express my participants
with the people of solihull following
this this week's terrible disaster
but we all know what today's
announcement is
it's a sock to the right wing press and
it continues here
's his obsession
with scapegoating Asylum Seekers
absolutely fast tracking applications
and weakening modern slavery protections
directly undermine wales's nation of
sanctuary policy which includes an
explicit commitment to prevent people
seeking Sanctuary from becoming victims
of modern slavery
so what discussions has he had with
Welsh government to guarantee fast
tracking won't won't frustrate our
ambition to be a proper nation of
sanctuary
Mr Speaker we were the first country in
the world thanks to the leadership of my
honorable friend from maidenhead to pass
the modern slavery act with a dedicated
regime which doesn't exist in its form
in basically any other European country
we require our businesses to enforce
their supply chains we have life
sentences for people who traffic modern
slaves so I'm very proud of our record
that record will continue but we do need
to make sure our system is not abused
and exploited and that's what we will
fix with our reforms Simon Clark
Mr Speaker and I I warmly welcome the
package of measure science today because
this is the key issue on the doorstep in
Middlesbrough savings and it's something
coaches care about very deeply the
package that's putting people together
is very very strong and of course it
complements as my writing friend said
the Rwanda agreement can he just confirm
however that if it is light Ruan that
ultimately frustrated by the European
convention on human rights that we will
rule nothing out including derogation to
make sure that we can deliver this vital
package prime minister Mr Speaker having
been on those doorsteps in Middlesbrough
Ralph with my uh our honorable friend I
know he speaks the truth and he's been
right to highlight this issue for his
constituents and what I can tell him is
we will legislate to put our Albania
proposals on a statutory footing I'm
highly confident that those should be
delivered and as I said they are already
in practice in all other European
countries there's no reason why they
shouldn't happen here too Chris Brown
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
said we will restart data sharing to
stop migrants getting bank accounts who
are we going to be be restarting the
data sharing with and why did we stop
Mr Speaker The Honorable member I'm sure
will remember after the wind Rush
situation data sharing was stopped in a
range of different places and has not
restarted we will be restarting data
sharing with the banks so that when
someone tries to open a new bank account
or indeed just on a quarterly basis for
existing bank accounts the banks will
have to check against the database of
illegal migrants that we hold to ensure
that people cannot disappear into the
black economy having arrived here
illegally and then participate in a
normal way that's not right it's not
fair and I'm glad that he'll be
supporting those proposals
I'm very pleased to hear the new
approach to albanians and that is both
obvious and very sensible but my
question to the Prime Minister Mr
Speaker is how we bridge the gap we have
a gap that we approve 76 of all Asylum
applications where the EU average is
just 14 we're all echr signatories they
are not held out as International priors
or breaking any abstract of
international law and he may be
surprised to hear that I have no issue
with the Ambit of the echr as long as we
have an outcome of about 14 as well so
my question to my right hand friend is
what has been going wrong with our
approvals and refusals process prime
minister okay let's say my honorable
makes uh makes an excellent point he's
absolutely right a big part of that
difference is how we're treating Albania
that will be changed as a result of our
guide new guidance and deal but more
broadly one of the changes we've made
today is to increase the threshold that
someone has to meet to be considered a
modern slave it was based on simply a
suspicion that someone maybe we are
changing that to make sure that there is
objective evidence that they are that
change will help us close down some of
those Grant rates but there's more work
to do and that's what our legislation
will deliver Laura Anderson
thank you Mr Speaker the white list of
countries designated safe is not new and
Albania has been on this list since 2014
so there's nothing new about this
announcement I welcome clearing the
backlog the Prime Minister just said
that the new workers would be employed
within the next nine to 12 months and
the whole backlog will be cleared from
its current state of 100 000 it was
three thousand when labor is in power in
the next same 12 months
without without the immigration
how will this circle be squared how will
the backlog be cleared prime minister
I just urge The Honorable lady to go
check her figures it was certainly a lot
harder than that in the last Labor
government but as my uh honor of thanet
made the point is it currently we we are
only rejecting 45 of Albanian Asylum
Seekers compared to All European
countries that are more like 98 to 100
so the changes we've made today will
ensure that our grant rate increases up
to the levels that we see elsewhere
that's a result of the new deal that
we've negotiated with Albania which will
give more Comfort to our caseworkers
combined with the new guidance that's
going to be issued which will mean that
we should as we want to return the vast
majority of Albanian migrants when they
come here they shouldn't be here Albania
is a safe and prosperous country and
they should go back there that's the
outfit thank you
um I thank my right honorable friend for
his uh for his statement and for the new
approach on Albania um as much as I
welcome the jobs I'll be grateful if my
right Uncle fan could confirm that this
will be a temporary and not a permanent
um new small boat's operational Command
Center in Dover and East Kent and in
relation to Safe countries and immediate
returns could my right Animal Friend
update the house on whether a date has
been set now for the summit with
President macron next year
Mr Speaker can I just first of all pay
tribute to my honorable friend for all
the work she does on this issue in her
constituency and she's right we want to
get through these challenges that we
Face to have a system where people don't
come here illegally and once we do that
of course we should be able to withdraw
down uh people and after we've got the
backlog cleared as well and she's also
right to highlight the importance of
working with the French that's why our
new deal is so important that there's
work to build on on that we're keen to
have that Summit as early as practically
possible but it's important that deliver
tangible outcomes and that's what the
Home Secretary and I are said about
doing do you want the children thank you
Mr Speaker yesterday I led a delegation
of the joint committee on human rights
to meet with the legal Affairs and human
rights committee of the Parliamentary
assembly of the Council of Europe and
one of the issues we discussed was the
importance that all Council of Europe
States address migration issues in
accordance with human rights and
international law and of course
International Refugee law does not
require Asylum Seekers to make their
claim in the first safe country and it
protects Asylum Seekers arriving via
irregular or unofficial routes provided
they make their presence known to the
authorities so can I ask the Prime
Minister this can you give me an
undertaking that his new laws will
comply with the United Kingdom's
international law and human rights
obligations and if not can he tell us
from which treaties he intends to
derogate or is it simply his intention
to flout international law and if that's
the case what kind of example does he
think that sends to other countries in
Europe particularly on its eastern
border
Mr Speaker and The Honorable lady will
know this that both the 1999 Immigration
Act the 2002 Immigration Act and indeed
at the Double agreement all actually
consider the a proposition that it is
possible to return people who have come
here who shouldn't be here it allows the
possibility to designate safe countries
and and to do removals so that principle
is well established in international law
what we want to have is a system where
if you come here illegally you will not
be able to stay that is a simple Common
Sense Fair principle that I think the
vast majority of the country is right
behind yeah
Mr Speaker to agree with every single
sentiment uh impulse and work yeah right
unless it's a speech of my own of course
but I did today and I congratulate the
Prime Minister yeah uh his his uh set of
measures about the site is appropriate
and it'll be appreciated across the
country will he as most of my
constituents would
when people travel across safe countries
as they frequently do before they claim
Asylum automatically assume that their
claim is spurious or at least doubtful
Mr Speaker and this is what our new
legislation will deliver it will make it
unambiguously clear that if you come
here illegally you will have no right to
stay you will be removed either back to
your own safe country or a safe
alternative if that is the right system
to have it's the fair system to have and
it means we can concentrate our
generosity and compassion on those
around the world who most need it and I
know that's the type of system that The
Honorable gentleman wants to see
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker we
shouldn't forget why we're actually here
with the statement today is because the
government has lost control of the
Asylum immigration system and Sean a
degree of incompetence which takes some
beating they've also failed three years
on to beat their Manifesto commitments
of taking back control of the Border
um that the new system would give real
control so can I ask the Prime Minister
this could he confirm and firm up his
earlier statement as he is confident
that the whole backlog will be removed
by the end of next year of the initial
Asylum decisions and could he tell us
why I didn't say anything about how long
he expects it will take to remove those
Asylum Seekers who have failed in their
applications out of the country
Madam Deputy speaker yes the initial our
plan is to clear the initial Asylum
backlog by the end of next year it's
about 117 000 uh currently on public
statistics but he talked about the
government and where we are I think he
he forget it forgets to mention that if
you look at what's happening currently
across Europe the number of Asylum
claims in France in Germany is all up by
50 and that's because the global
migratory patterns have completely
enough Lee changed it's why the current
system is Obsolete and it's why we need
to take steps to adopt to the new regime
and ensure we have proper control of our
borders that's what our reforms will
deliver Damien green
I'm Japanese speaker I very strongly
support the measures the Prime Minister
has announced this morning and in
particular his framing of it as a matter
of fairness because I think having tough
but fair border controls and an asylum
policy is exactly where the British
people are and in communities across the
country would he agree with me that
communities including my own
constituents the measure of success the
visible measure of success will be when
some of the hotels currently being used
for housing the Asylum Seekers can
actually be returned to their normal use
and will he make that a priority prime
minister can I can I thank my right
honorable friend uh both for absolutely
championing this issue for his
constituents but also the advice that he
has provided the Home Secretary and I
given his experience in how best to
tackle the problems that we face I very
much value and appreciate that support
he's absolutely right I think what
people want to see is our hotels going
back to what they're used for normally
in their communities but also flights
departing removing people who should not
be here the Home Secretary the
immigration Minister I will work
tirelessly to deliver that for him and
for the country
Caroline Lucas thank you madam Deputy
speaker the Prime Minister talks about
Fair get what he set out as the very
opposite of a fair and efficient system
the best way to stop desperate people
dying in small boats on the criminal
gangs is for the government to promote
more safe and legal routes why is the
government so incapable of doing that
effectively why can he find 500 new
staff for his Albanian scheme but only
eight people to process the eleven
thousand Asylum applications from
Afghanistan which means that contrary to
what the Secretary of State suggested in
this chamber barely an hour ago it is
the case that there have been zero
Afghans resettled from Afghanistan under
the acrs pathway 3 since January
well Mr Speaker we've in fact settled
over 23 000 people from Afghanistan
safely in this country she talks about
safer legal routes we actually issued in
the last year more humanitarian visas
than in any other year since the second
world war that is that strength and
depth of our compassion that's what we
will always do but we can't have that
compassion and generosity exploited by
people who break the rules there's
nothing fair about that and it does
nothing to help the people that we
really need to Target and that's what we
will do David Simmons
Madam Deputy speaker but I commend the
Prime Minister on the approach that he's
outlined today and ask him two questions
firstly are there plans to examine the
processes which other European
conventions of Human Rights States use
which enable them to be so much more
robust in the way that they deal with
these issues within the law and secondly
will he commit to working with those
other countries to develop safe and
legal groups so together we can ensure
that this robust approach applies in the
same way as it does as other countries
in the United Kingdom prime minister I
thank my animal friends an excellent
question and the answer simply is is yes
that is what we have done over the past
few weeks and that's what we will
continue to do and our Albania deal
Builds on exactly that learning but
where we can learn from other countries
about how to do this faster and better
with a higher rejection rate that's
exactly what we want to achieve with his
support I know we can do it Alison
McGovern
gee speaker I'm a bit worried because
whilst the Prime Minister might be okay
with his cheerleaders in here I think
that he's out of touch because the
British public do the public do you know
Madam Deputy speaker who has been in
charge for the past 12 years
so as a matter of accountability can I
ask the prime minister
which of the decisions it is that he
would point to whilst he was sat around
the cabinet table that means that the
backlog is now 14 times as big as it was
when labor left office
Mr Speaker difficult as with the backlog
is half the size that it was when laser
were in office if she needs to get her
numbers right as she talks about the
British people I tell you madam Deputy
speaker what the British people want is
an asylum system that says when you come
here illegally you cannot stay here
because that's not right it's
if she wants to be on the side of the
British people she should back our new
legislation
[Applause]
speaker and I would like to uh thank my
right honorable friend for the measures
that he's outlined today and
particularly thank him for his personal
determination to find practical
solutions to a very real problem but but
can I ask my uh right honorable friends
that uh in my constituency the home
office with Clear Springs their
contractor have identified a disused
building
um in my constituency to use the
dispersal accommodation whilst our very
much welcome the move from hotels to
more permanent accommodation will my
right honorable friend make sure that
the um concerns and worries or listen to
that at home office listen to the local
Authority the police and public health
and make sure that we are deciding on
locations that are appropriate and
suitable
yeah I'm really happy to hear from my
honorable friend and this is an issue
which she has right long championed I
know she has spoken to the immigration
Minister about her concerns in her local
area I thank her for her constructive
attitude in working with us which is
absolutely right we will sit and listen
to her and her local Authority about
what's appropriate and deliver sensible
Solutions
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
um
because existing systems feel so
miserably with Asylum Seekers and hotels
throughout the kingdom Azure once again
be meeting with Asylum Seekers and my
constituency prior to Christmas prime
minister decanting them to
the shoes holding Parks former Center
homes and surplus Community sites does
not solve the problem when can I tell
them that they will be allowed to sit
down with an official from a home office
so they can start their legal process of
immigration
speaker the ownership is right what will
solve the problem is stopping people
coming here illegally in the first place
that's how we'll solve the hotel problem
that's what our new legislation will
deliver and I hope that he will support
it
warmly welcome the prime minister's
action plan to tackle the problem of
Small Boat Crossings and thank him for
being true to his word in prioritizing
this issue the big issue in Kettering is
that the Royal Hotel which is slap bang
in the middle of the town has been
designated as a Asylum Hotel it's one of
the most completely inappropriate
settings you could imagine will the
Prime Minister reassure my constituents
in Kettering that the plan he's
announced today will be the quickest way
to end the use of such Hotel
accommodation
I thank my honorable friend and he's
absolutely right to stand up for his
constituents but he's also absolutely
right to highlight that our approach is
the best way to relieve the pressure on
local services including the use of
hotels so that we can return them back
to their Everyday Use and the way we
will do that fast is is by providing
alternative sites that we're working on
but also stopping the flow of small
boats and that's what our plan will
deliver
Alex Cunningham the Most Wanted actually
speaker we've many thousands of Asylum
Seekers across taste site I'm personally
very proud of how welcoming our
communities can be but my team in
Stockton they're working with many of
these Asylum Seekers and they've waited
years and years and years for their
Asylum applications to be processed and
they're rated in Despair and fear all
they want is a decision how many of them
can expect one in the next few months
well Madam Deputy speaker the home
sector and I want to see exactly the
same thing that's why with our new plan
we will cut the initial Asylum backlog
by the end of next year people should
get Swift processing but in order to
deliver that sustainably we need to
reduce the pressure on the system and
that means stopping the flow of new
illegal migrants coming here
Laura Faris thank you madam Deputy
speaker it is absolutely right that
there is alignment with our main
European counterparts in how we deal
with Asylum claims from safe countries
and so I congratulate my right honorable
friend on the agreement with Albania
given the automatic return principle
that will apply to arrivals from Albania
there will be an incentive to try and
conceal their true country of origin on
arrival we already know that that is a
problem with the channel Crossings with
people dispensing of their ID documents
mid-crossing often at the direction of
the people Smugglers so an in
anticipation of this issue can my right
honorable friend reassure the house that
there will be a sufficiently robust
evidential threshold that will prevent
people from falsifying prime minister
that's an excellent suggestion from my
honorable friend and I thank her for it
I'll also just give her the reassurance
that for the first time we will have
British officials stationed in Albania
particularly at Toronto Airport and
Albanian officials here in the UK in in
order to deal with the problem that she
identified and I'm confident that that
joint working will help us deliver the
solution that we want
Alison Taylor thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker his statement today could
not be more out of touch with the people
that come to my surgeries week in week
out and I have the highest immigration
caseload in Scotland so can you tell me
why Mr H has been waiting no years past
August for his family reunion he's from
Afghanistan or Mr E has been waiting to
see his family as well why why these men
come to my surgeries in tears because
they cannot get reunited with their
families his safe and legal Roots the
truth is are just not working and for
those that don't even have the The
Misfortune to be from Afghanistan if
they're from other countries there is no
legal route that's why so many people
are coming here in books that is the
truth of the situation and will he
accept that it is unreasonable to make
people wait as long as he is in absolute
misery waiting for a decision that just
isn't coming yeah
well Mr Speaker I do want people to wait
and that's why we need to stop the flow
of illegal migrants coming here because
they put unsustainable pressure on the
system and mean that we cannot process
for her constituents and others as
quickly as we would like to but with the
new plan we've put in place we will be
able to and once we pass new legislation
to stop the flow of small boats we will
of course have far less pressure on the
system and be able to get people the
decisions they need
I warmly welcome the Prime Minister
statement who will answer many of the
concerns expressed to me by constituents
in Barry and across the veil of
Glamorgan and not only is it the
comprehensive nature but also the
detailed approach that my right
honorable friend is taking a practical
steps in order to resolve this problem
but in spite of the calls opposite does
my right honorable friend recognize that
this is a dynamic environment that will
constantly evolve and change and will he
remain open-minded to extending the
regulations and tightening the
regulations where necessary to respond
to the Ingenuity and Innovation shown by
some of these people traffickers my
Royal friend makes an excellent point
and we need to remain Dynamic and Nimble
to uh the new challenges we face I said
this won't be an easy problem to fix it
won't be one that we can do overnight
but I am confident that if we apply
ourselves in the way that I've set out
we will be able to stop the flow of
illegal migrants over the time and I
welcome his support in doing that
Patrick Grady Deputy speaker how much of
what the prime minister is announcing
today is going to be paid for out of the
eight budget
Mr Speaker actually under the uh DAC
oecd rules the first year of
resettlement costs for Asylum Seekers is
actually covered uh by International
grievance on Aid uh the chancellor has
provided extra funding to deal with some
of the pressures that we're seeing as a
result of the 150 000 ukrainians that
are here and we remain one of the
largest Spenders on International
Development anywhere in the world and
that's something that we can all be very
proud of
Jack Claritin thank you madam speaker
very much welcome what the Prime
Minister has announced today and as he
knows Stoke on Trent has more than our
fair share of Asylum Seekers and
refugees this has put significant
pressure on services on Council Services
schools hospitals and also on the police
so will my iPhone friend Luca what more
can be done to put in place the money
and the financial support to support
those services
can I thank my honorable friend uh he's
absolutely right can I can I pay tribute
to his local community and the local
Council in Stoke for what they do they
do go over above and beyond to provide
support but he's right they deserve our
support too I know the immigration
Minister has recently met with the
council and will continue to be engaged
with him
food
thank you madam Deputy speaker back in
the summer border checks on the land
border between Albania and Kosovo were
relaxed so that there was no need for
citizens of either state to register at
the border when Crossing
according to instat more than two and a
half million people entered Kosovo from
Albania in 2021 when I was traveling
between London and Pristina about 20
years ago I was stopped and questioned
by British border staff will the
government be embedding UK border force
staff at Pristina airport given that the
national and the cultural border between
Albania and Kosovo is a porous one
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
his suggestion I'm sure something the
Home Secretary will discuss with her
counterparts but his broad point is
right is right that we have for the
first time now UK officials in Albania
working closely with the Albanian
authorities to disrupt the flow of
illegal migrants at source and I'll take
his suggestion on board Celine Saxby
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I'd
like to thank my right honorable friend
for his work on this issue to in order
to take the opportunity to thank the
people Foundation the volunteers and GPS
who are currently looking after those
seeking asylum in a hotel badly placed
in ilfracombe come on my honorable
friend confirm that as he plans to
streamline this Asylum system that the
single mum and her eight-month-old
daughter that on Monday will make a
10-hour round trip to Cardiff to have
their Biometrics an interview that items
like that will no longer take place as
things improve
well can I pay tribute to her local
community in ilfrakum for the support
that they're providing and they deserve
credit and praise for that and she's
right we want to have a processing
system that is both Humane but also
Swift and effective for people and
that's what our reforms will deliver
Jim Shannon I can um speaker can I thank
the play Master for for a statement for
what is a very clearly a complex and
difficult issue and and trying to find
the way forward uh the the Prime
Minister has outlined the further steps
that can't be taken to Halt their legal
Crossings which are saying people lose
their lives in Dreadful winter weather
and that includes working alongside the
French government and Port Authorities
to prevent these trips being commenced
but will the the Prime Minister use
private companies with expertise with
skills with high ethical standards uh I
I finished a home sanctity with some
information and resident of one those
contact details on who are keen and able
to help and assist
yeah well I'm a Madam Deputy speaker I
thank my honorable friend for his
contribution uh he's right this is a
complex issue we're happy to look at all
uh different ways that we can make a
difference so I look forward to taking
his suggestion on board and the Home
Secretary heard what he said sir Edward
Lee
um I I was at the legal Affairs
committee at the Council of Europe uh
alluded to by The Honorable lady for
Edinburgh South West and the legal Point
she makes is entirely right and it has
to be addressed by the government as a
very serious point it is possible under
present legislation to uh arrest
somebody who lands on our Shores and
detain them but under nationalities act
actually very few have because there are
not legal routes that these people can
take now I'm not in favor of the
argument used by the opposition to have
more open legal Roots because with 100
million displaced people in the world is
just a policy that leads nowhere but we
have to address this point the problem
is every time we pass new legislation it
is trumped by human rights lawyers who
correctly and the law appeals the
refugee convention and the convention of
Human Rights and the human rights act so
will my right honorable friend assure me
that if this new legislation doesn't
work we will consider a derogation from
the convention on refugees
prime minister I thank my honorable
friend for his excellent question and
what our legislation will deliver as a
system whereby if somebody comes here
illegally they will not have the right
to stay and will be able to remove them
to their own country or a safe third
country that's the system of migration
that I think he wants to see his
constituents want to see and that this
government will deliver
Dr Luke Evans thank you madam Deputy
speaker and may I thank the Prime
Minister the Home Secretary and indeed
the senior home officials who I've had
follow-up with about the unacceptable
process of allocating a hotel in Earl
shield and I'm grateful for the changes
that we've seen But in his speech he
talked about the unfair and appalling
that we are spending 5.5 million a day
on this system it's unfair to those who
are housed there it's unfair to the
communities who see people spending this
money and unfair to the taxpayer he
talked to go on and say he's identified
10 000 spaces could he say when those
will come forward and people will be
moved on out of the hotels
well this is something that my uh right
on my friend immigration minister is
working on at PACE you know we're keen
to move as quickly as we can and secure
value for money for the taxpayer through
these commercial negotiations but we
think most of these sites can be brought
on around half the cost of hotels that
represents a significant saving and
we're keen to deliver it as quickly as
possible
um I do want to be able to call
everybody but that says require
short questions Dr Caroline Johnson
thank you
because living in limbo in a hotel with
an uncertain future is extremely
stressful so I do welcome my writing
friends plans to get these things
process as quickly as possible but
processing them is only the first step
you talk to 117 000 claims does he have
the capacity in the system to ensure
that the these people wants their claim
is successful are moved into permanent
accommodation and if it's not successful
that they're removed quickly
um my uh one of my friends absolutely
right we not only want to process people
swiftly but then have the ability to
either integrate them in their Community
as is required and we've done uh
brilliantly with some of our other
schemes but then remove them if they're
no longer should be here which is why
one of the strands of what we're working
on is strengthening and tightening up
our returns agreements with countries
because that should be a key part of our
diplomacy and we must have the ability
to return people to Safe countries and
that's something that we will work on
next year as well
Richard Fuller Deputy speaker I may I
welcome the prime minister's
comprehensive statements today including
his willingness to reform assessment
processes but can I ask him about
accountability when we see so many
government processes to improve and
achieve a policy outcome the public
don't see the outcome achieved and
they're worried that officials and
agencies are not held properly to
account to achieve those objectives so
what was his thoughts on this matter in
achieving the posi outcomes he's
outlined today
well Madam Deputy speaker I'm confident
because in the Home Secretary and the
immigration Minister we've got a crack
team and I know that they will work
tirelessly with their teams to drive
through the reforms that we are
announcing today his right to hold us
account for that there will be
transparent metrics that are published
on a quarterly basis already with regard
to processing for example but people
will want to see flights leaving with
those being returned to Albania and
elsewhere and people coming out of
hotels that's what we want to deliver
next year
Jane hunt thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker the independent Chief
Inspector of the Border agency found in
July 2006 that there was a backlog of
between 400 000 and 450 000 cases on
that basis this announcement is very
welcome and I would like to thank the
Prime Minister for taking hold of this
issue please could I ask when we will
see an actual reduction in the number of
people in hotels across the country and
what capacity will we have to maintain
those who claim Asylum and have a valid
claim in other facilities rather than
hotels across the UK
well I'm Keen to deliver as the
immigration Minister and Home Secretary
alternative sites as quickly as we can
commercially negotiate them and get them
up and running I want to see what she
wants to see which is people moving out
of hotels less pressure on local
communities and that's a type of
accommodation we want to deliver Richard
Graham
Mr Speaker I thank the Prime Minister
and the government for their great
progress on this immigration action plan
including particularly progress with
both the unhcr and Albania he will know
that the key to this is in delivery
because what we don't want in Gloucester
is for the situation to be as it was in
May 2010 when my labor predecessor not
only refused to hand over any casework
files at all but we subsequently found
over 4 000 Asylum cases some of whom
have been waiting for resolution for
over 10 years
trip well my honorable friend has ever
makes a very powerful point and I I
agree with him we need to deliver now
we've got a plan in place that's what
we'll be uh focused on next year for his
constituency for the country and I am
confident that we can do it David Jones
Deputy speaker could I refer my right
honorable friend to the point just made
by my right honorable friend the member
for Gainsborough can he confirm
specifically that the legislation to be
introduced next year will deal with the
impediments set up by the European
convention on human rights
speaker our legislation will deliver a
system whereby if somebody comes here
illegally will have they will have no
right to stay and they will be removed
to their own country or a safe Third
Country alternative I think that is a
system that the British people want to
see that is the system that our
legislation will deliver
basically you should have no right
whatsoever to stay here and should be
swiftly deported it really is as simple
as that my commend the Prime Minister
for his bold statement today and looking
to legislate to this ends does he agree
with me that starting flights to Rwanda
as soon as possible is absolutely
integral to delivering this plan okay so
my honorable friend put it clearly uh
succinctly and very well I completely
agree with him and we are Keen to
restart those flights as soon as we can
uh we'll wait the next stage of our
legal proceedings but he should be in no
doubt that we'd remain determined to
make that policy work okay longy
speaker can I thank the Prime Minister
and the Home Secretary for their renewed
focus on this really key point that
matters a lot not just to my
constituents of Dudley North but across
the country could I again address the
point at the right honorable member for
gains were made and perhaps be a bit
more specific with the question if his
future legislation is indeed scuppered
by an intervention by the Judiciary or
human rights activists uh lawyers will
he have the political will to still
force it through and Implement what he
intends to do
yeah well Madam Deputy speaker first of
all can I thank my honorable friend for
all the engagement he's had with me and
the Home Secretary on this issue I know
how important it is to his constituents
uh and hopefully he is pleased by the
steps we are taking today but he's right
we need to go further that's why our new
legislation will make it unequivocally
clear that those who come here illegally
have no right to stay and his community
should be confident that that's what
this government will deliver Robin
Miller Madam electric speaker I thank my
old friend for his personal attention to
this matter and I welcome his idea for
or ambition for a fair and effective
system rooted in and understanding that
world has changed since the 1950s but
the devil is in the detail and on a
practical Point dozens of hotels have
short-term three-month contracts with
the home office to deliver emergency
accommodation for Asylum Seekers right
across the UK my concern is and my
residence concern is this will he
reassure us please that these contracts
will not simply be renewed quietly and
simply rolled over but will actually be
so to the same level of scrutiny that is
Promised on new contracts including
consultation with the MP the council and
local public services
[Music]
my honorable friend makes an excellent
point and I will make sure that the home
office looks at that properly and does
look at these things not with a kind of
automaticity which he suggested might
happen but review them afresh and make
sure that they're still fit for purpose
and I think he makes a good point
jenkinson Thank you madam Deputy speaker
and kind of thank my red honorable from
the Prime Minister for his significant
engagement in recent weeks on this and
other issues
um for the benefit of my constituents
across working tin can he set out his
expected time skills on a removal of the
threat of unsuitable Hotel accommodation
in workington being used and B flights
leaving the ground to Rwanda
well Madam Deputy speaker what I can
tell his constituents in community is
that we want to deliver on this as soon
as practically possible our new deal
with Albania will take effect in a
matter of weeks so we will be able to
swiftly return people back to Albania
those that are already here and any new
arrivals uh he knows that we're keen to
press on with finding new sites as soon
as we can commercially negotiate them to
take people out of hotels and of course
with regard to Rwanda we are waiting for
the latest court judgment but he should
be in no doubt that we want to deliver
on that policy Greg Smith I'm Deputy
speaker I'm grateful to the Prime
Minister for making this a top priority
and look forward to backing the
legislation in the new year but turning
to the legislation we've already got
there are significant powers of
detention in the nationality and borders
act and Willie look again at how we can
Implement those at the very least for
those who are accused of committing
heinous crimes particularly against
children yeah my one of a friend is
right we do have new powers particularly
on the enforcement side we are very keen
to use them to strengthen the deterrent
impact but as he knows we need to go
further and that's what our new
legislation will do Ben Spencer thank
you my name is
welcome my rational friends announcement
today and he's absolutely right uh
people living in many Midway Bridge want
to see furnace in the system which this
announcement will deliver but can I
particularly welcome the new returns
agreement to Albania and does he agree
with me that
um solving the gold you're not here is
the importance of having multiple return
agreements with multiple countries so
that when people's applications are
processed and found wanting they can be
returned swiftly
prime minister is absolutely right as a
matter of priority we're looking at
those countries where we already in fact
have returns agreements but are not
sufficiently able to send people back we
will renew our diplomatic efforts to
make that a priority but also use Visa
penalties where appropriate to get the
outcomes that we need
Tom Hunt Deputy speaker I welcome our
prime minister now today and also his
personal attention is devoted to this my
constituents can continue to be
concerned about the use of a nove hotel
in Ipswich which is on a 12 month
contract I thought it was six I was told
by the home office it was but it was
actually turned out to be 12 but that's
why we buy um and I'm very much welcome
to move towards cheaper and more basic
accommodation
um could the Prime Minister May perhaps
indicate to me when my conceptions may
get a sense of a Time scan of when a
Novotel can be back in proper use
well I share his and his constituents
frustration that their local hotel as so
many others are being currently used to
house illegal migrants that's wrong we
want to stop it as quickly as we can the
immigration minister is working on
alternative sites uh as fast as possible
but also we want to stop the flow of new
illegal migrants so there isn't
unsustainable pressure on our local
Services that's what he wants his
community wants that's what we will
deliver James Grundy thank you madam
Deputy speaker earlier this year my
local paper the Lee Journal wrote about
the human misery inflicted on the
constituency of Lee via Balkans ocg that
was engaging in people trafficking but
we've heard from some in the opposition
today that there is I quote no such
thing as an illegal Asylum Seeker would
you agree that that is sadly not the
case and we have to face reality if we
are to deal with this issue yeah yeah my
Marvel friend makes an excellent and
very clear point the issue today is
illegal migration it has significantly
increased in the past couple of years is
it's putting unsustainable pressure on
our local communities and public
services it must end and our reforms are
a significant step forward in delivering
that outcome I'm in pain thank you madam
Deputy speaker having been briefly the
minister attacking illegal migration
this summer I warmly welcome the prime
minister's statement could he provide
more details about how the new small
boats operational command will help to
ensure that no small boat can arrive
undetected on our Shores
well I thank my honorable friend for his
support of our approach the new small
boat operational command will bring
together our civilian capabilities our
military and the NCA in a more unified
way than before supplement that with new
technology whether it's surveillance
aerial or land-based drones and radar
and in doing all of that we'll be able
to maintain an exceptionally High
interception rate and increase the level
of prosecutions that we're currently
seeing and I know that's something that
he will want to see happen
oh uh Jonathan
thank you madam Deputy speaker the
people of Stoke-on-Trent North kids
Grove and talk will warmly welcome
albeit cautiously because they want to
see delivery on the ground the Prime
Minister statement but the mask has
slickman deck speak on The Late party
where they were absent throughout the
majority of statement in their North
Islington coffee bars drinking chai
latte and scoffing down quinoa but it is
up to over 1900 people have now signed a
petition called end circles abuse of
stove content because they're too busy
taking up our hotels in fact named depth
speaker the prime minister's own
constituents have signed the petition in
this course so will the Prime Minister
agree with my constituents and his an
end Circa using hotels in
stoke-on-trents can I uh can I thank my
honorable friend but also his local
community for the way in which they have
approached this problem and the support
that they give to people who need Refuge
but he's right that we can't exploit
that generosity can't exploit that
compassion it's right that we relieve
the pressure on hotels that's what our
plan will deliver But ultimately what we
all want to see and the people in state
on Trump want to see is an end to the
boats coming and that's what this
government will deliver
and thank the prime minister
[Music]
point of order Alex cunning
ham thank you very much Deputy speaker
we seem to have been waiting for many
years for the Tobacco Control plan for
the government a plan to reduce and then
eradicate smoking in our communities by
2030. sadly despite promises from a
series of Health ministers we're still
waiting now we hear of mixed reports of
what the government's plans may be on
both funding and the proposal to
increase the age of which people can buy
tobacco products now many thousands of
people can continue to die from smoking
every year and many more suffer chronic
ill health and we need action now have
you had any indication from the
government that they plan to publish the
Tobacco Control plan and or make a
statement not just on the 2030 Target
but also that policy going forward
uh well I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for his point of order and for giving me
notice of it
um I can tell the honorable gentleman
that I've had no indication from the
government that they intended to make a
statement on this subject but I am very
aware that he has a well-occupied
treasury front bench and I'm sure they
will have noted his comments and I'm
sure feed his concerns back thank you